les petites choses qui frétille les
milices le père qui défend son sa petite
fille qui s'est fait agresser
sexuellement qui a 6 ans qui fout une
demi-rousse d'un abruti malsain qui
passe qui est en examen enfin attendez
on est dans un monde à l'envers bon
c'est que le vivre ensemble il est
encore un avenir en France je sais pas
moi je me suis inscrit un club de tir
vous me posez une question ça veut dire
quoi ça défendre il vaut mieux oui
est-ce que je suis pour les armes non
est-ce que je suis pour la violence non
merci d'avion d'être là merci mon Adèle
Daniel Guichard que j'adore il le sait
bon Daniel il sait que il sait que que
je l'aime fort Daniel merci d'être là ça
fait plaisir je suis très content de te
voir et c'est vrai que toi tu es une des
dernières grandes gueules encore
concernant le tir et le côté humain du
tir oui c'était un peu excessif mais
c'était bien
merci Daniel non mais alors Daniel c'est
vrai qu'il y a cette affaire qui a fait
énormément parler tout le monde a dit on
t'a dit que tu penses du vivre ensemble
et tu as dit je me suis inscrit un club
de tir et alors comment ça s'est passé
en fait tu t'es dit ouais j'ai alors on
pourrait prendre ça au deuxième degré et
se dire c'est une grosse connerie parce
que le fait d'aller s'inscrire à un club
de tir ne te donne pas le droit d'aller
flinguer tous les gens qui vous en la
rue déjà au départ mais c'est une façon
de répondre il y a tellement de choses
qui se disent sur les difficultés du
vivre ensemble on se dit ok bon on
m'aurait posé la question est-ce que tu
veux vivre à la campagne isolée je me
serais inscrit pour passer le de
conduire histoire de pas être toujours
isolé mais c'est vrai que ça fait une
angine ça fait énormément après Daniel
c'est un mec voilà moi je suis un voilà
parce qu'il dit des choses
qu'aujourd'hui on a plus des mecs comme
lui 100 francs parler Daniel mais très
franchement c'est pas anodin de dire je
n'ai rien est anodin on va pas on va pas
il va te défoncer thématiquement se dire
qu'on est dans un monde de bisounours et
qu'il faut s'inscrire un club de tir
pour flinguer tout ce qui bouge c'est
pas ça l'esprit parce que vous voulez
dire quand même c'est je m'inscris un
club de tir parce qu'on sait jamais je
peux en avoir besoin un jour
éventuellement d'une arme pour me
défendre c'est ce que vous voulez dire
non mais c'est possible dans ces cas-là
on va aller jusqu'au fond du
raisonnement et on se dit jamais je
ferai de mal à qui que ce soit parce que
j'ai jamais fait j'ai jamais tué
personne mais il est vraiment une
réalité si quelqu'un passait le mur de
chez moi pour faire du mal à ma femme et
mes enfants je sais que dans les minutes
qui suivraient ma vie basculerait que je
finir en prison mais qui passerai plus
jamais le mur voilà exactement
[Applaudissements]
exactement
on se met bien d'accord on se fait pas
juste ici soi-même bien sûr on tire pas
sur les gens parce qu'ils ont une
tronche qui te revient pas mais il y a
une réalité il faut toujours vivre avec
l'idée de se dire que peut-être
malheureusement on sera un jour obligé
de se défendre chez soi mais non pas
dehors mais non il y a la police pour ça
je suis obligé d'applaudir non c'est la
police autoritaire mais non mais la
police est fait ce qu'elle peut la
justice elle fait ce qu'elle peut la
majorité des gens vivent comme ils
peuvent bien les uns avec les autres
quel que soit le pays d'où ils viennent
mais il y en a quelques-uns de temps en
temps qui se disent on n'a pas on n'a
pas d'obligation de respecter les règles
on va pas revenir sur l'histoire de la
petite fille qui a eu un problème avec
un titre qui passait et que le père a
chopé et il en a mis deux et alors plein
de gens se disent on aurait eu on aurait
peut-être fait pire la police elle fait
ce qu'elle peut elle est pas là partout
mais on peut pas faire justice soi-même
mais attention j'ai jamais dit j'étais
là pour faire la justice moi-même mais
j'ai dit ne passez pas le mur de chez
moi pour faire du mal au mien c'est tout
exactement chez toi alors
c'est où exactement je te donnerai
l'adresse tu peux venir essayer
[Applaudissements]
j'entends votre votre peur légitime et
votre crainte voilà votre crainte malgré
tout vous savez que votre discours est
difficilement enfin évidemment je suis
comme Gilles je vais être minoritaire
sur ce coup-là mais c'est un peu c'est
aussi la porte ouverte au dérapages
c'est aussi la porte ouverte à
éventuellement il y a une ombre je tire
et ça peut et moi j'ai pas envie
pardonnez-moi mais je n'ai pas envie
d'être de vivre comme aux États-Unis
avec un Français sur deux qui armé avec
des gosses qui éventuellement vont
trouver l'arme de papa et qui vont se
buter avec des portiques dans les écoles
si on est inscrit un club de tir c'est
pas pour autant qu'on a le droit d'avoir
des armes à la maison il faut avoir une
certaine compétence pour avoir des armes
et quand on a des armes elles sont dans
une armoire fermée et on ne peut pas
faire ce qu'on veut avec les armes on
peut pas se balader avec des flingues on
peut pas faire peur aux gens en leur
mettant sous le nez mais il est une
règle c'est que les armes sont des
choses dangereuses même les chasseurs
on a un permis de chasse mais on peut
pas faire n'importe quoi avec un fusil
le côté d'avoir la frayeur que les armes
vont se trimballer partout qui en aura
partout dans les pièces non faut être
raisonnable à quoi ça sert
parce qu'on est obligé de se concentrer
c'est pas parce qu'on est dans un club
de tir qu'on peut tirer en disant il
faut absolument se calmer il faut
absolument maîtriser c'est une
discipline olympique le tir c'est pas
Jean-Marie Guillaume tu voulais pas dans
cette vidéo vous faites référence à
l'affaire dont on a parlé sur splato
avec ce père de famille qui a voulu se
faire justice lui-même avec quelqu'un
qui a voulu il a pas fait vraiment
justice parce que peut-être qu'il aurait
bien pu faire pire exactement en fait
moi ce qui me gêne parfois c'est qu'on
entend des gens qui ont peur mais qui se
base sur des choses qu'elles ont entendu
dans les métiers
et moi je me pose la question du rôle
des médias en général dans cette
histoire est-ce que par là pourquoi bah
est-ce qu'on peut il a raison d'un fait
divers à la télé est-ce que ça veut dire
que ça peut arriver à chaque point de
rue c'est la question que je me pose je
crois pas mais c'est toujours
sous-jacent il existe une espèce
d'ambiance malsaine qui fait que
d'ailleurs sur cette sur cet exemple on
m'a posé des questions pendant deux
heures j'ai parlé de plein de choses et
on a retenu que 10 secondes donc ça veut
dire qu'il y a un certain esprit qui un
jour là je sais Daniel que c'était
c'était à la suite aussi de la faire
Lola qui a fait
c'est vrai que voilà
et c'est vrai que on était tous et on
l'a encore bien entendu tous vraiment
sur les nerfs on était je le sentais moi
aussi tout le monde ici sur le plateau
après cette affaire on sait tous mis à
la place de des des parents de Lola de
la famille on y arrive pas et je pense
que c'est ça aussi qui a joué dans ce
que tu as dit aussi il y avait l'affaire
Lola il y a eu ce jeune à Roanne ce que
tu as dit cette jeune fille avec son
papa qui a donc c'est vrai que voilà je
pense ça sera plus des choses qui se
sont passées dans les années précédentes
j'ai le souvenir de gens qui ont
manifesté pour faire libérer un vieux
monsieur qui a eu peur qui a parfois les
gendarmes et qui disait il y a des gens
chez moi venez vite j'ai des gens chez
moi venez vite bon il a pas tué les deux
personnes qui étaient là il les a
blessées il s'est quand même fait de la
cabane est-ce qu'il avait raison est-ce
qu'il avait tort peut-être pas mais il a
eu peur pendant un moment et il a
téléphoné il y a des les enregistrements
de la gendarmerie
qu'est-ce qu'on fait dans ces cas là on
se fait tuer on se fait mettre en
morceaux moi si je dois être obligé
malheureusement de faire mal à quelqu'un
parce que je pourrais pas faire
autrement pour défendre ma famille je le
ferai tu as déjà fait ma vie sera foutu
le lendemain mais ça sera comme ça tu as
déjà eu peur Daniel tu as déjà eu un
truc qui est arrivé et tu t'es dit ouais
je vais ça va basculer ma vie va
basculer ça m'est arrivé une fois ou
deux oui mais dans ces cas-là on se dit
on n'est pas passé loin quoi on n'est
pas on n'est pas on peut pas résister à
tout ce qui peut arriver franchement je
pose la question aux uns et aux autres
si votre proche votre mari votre femme
vos enfants risquent leur vie en
quelques secondes et que vous ne pouvez
pas faire autrement que de tuer ou de
blesser gravement est-ce que vous allez
hésiter en disant je vais peut-être
appeler le 10ème question pour toi voilà
c'est ça qu'est-ce que tu fais toi alors
je réponds je ne tirerai jamais je
n'aurais jamais d'armes
pourquoi tirer sur quelqu'un ben je
ferai ce que je peux Cyril
j'interviendrai c'est sûr que je me
jetterais si quelqu'un tire sur un
projet je me mets au milieu je prends la
balle voilà mais moi-même je ne pourrais
pas dire mais non mais ça bouffe ça peut
vous paraître un aveu de faiblesse mais
moi je dirais jamais je suis contre la
violence comme ça donc
il y a quelqu'un qui rentre chez toi
c'est ce que disait Daniel il y a
quelqu'un qui rentre chez toi je crie je
hurle je le repousse etc mais si j'ai
une arme je ne tire pas et moi une arme
tu ne tire pas non je ne tire pas et moi
ce qui m'inquiète dans les propos de
Daniel que je respecte totalement c'est
vous allez au club de tir vous savez
très bien qu'après vous pouvez avoir
avoir une arme si vous avez si vous
devenez tireur sportif est-ce que vous
allez vous en servir de cette arme moi
c'est ça qui m'inquiète ça dépend de la
situation
dans la situation chaque fois qu'il y a
un bruit de sourire chaque fois qu'il y
a un bruit de souris un chat qui passe
on va pas prendre un flingue pour dire
bien sûr mais selon les situations et
selon les circonstances peut-être que ça
sera un morceau de bois peut-être que ça
sera une bouteille peut-être que ça sera
un couteau mais moi je me dis si quelque
chose devait arriver de gravissime à mes
proches et à ma famille je me
sacrifierai pas en disant tuez-moi parce
qu'ils tueront les autres après parce
que le principe il est simple les des
grands malades il y en a malheureusement
pas beaucoup heureusement pour nous
parce que la situation est de si on est
quand même impossivisé mais ça arrive de
temps en temps il faut pas vivre avec
cet appréhension permanente mais même si
on fait une plaisanterie en disant je
m'inscris un club de tir ça justifie pas
qu'on passe deux plans en disant
qu'est-ce qu'on fait j'en sais rien
peut-être que je tirerais pas peut-être
que je balancerai une bouteille un coup
de couteau une chaise quelque chose mais
je ferai en sorte que le danger n'existe
plus tu as toujours envie de rentrer
chez
parce que c'est c'est notre c'est notre
époque actuelle qui moi je pense que
c'est dangereux d'avoir une arme chez
soi c'est vrai qu'on peut faire c'est
dangereux d'avoir une arme moi me fait
peur oui mais on est obligé quand même
de l'enfermer dans une armoire on peut
pas la laisser comme ça
se compte par milliers aux États-Unis et
une armoire c'est pas une sécurité aux
États-Unis
non mais ce qu'on va pas le devenir
c'est ça le risque je ne souhaiterais
pas qu'elle devienne quand même aux
États-Unis il y a eu 611 fusillades de
masse faut quand même le dire les armes
circule facilement il y a des états en
aux États-Unis où tu peux te balader
avec ton flingue en apparence sans
problème moi je trouve je comprends
Daniel ce que vous dites tout à fait
évidemment sur le coup de la colère ou
de la peur évidemment de la défense pas
de la colère mais si on n'est pas
capable de se contrôler faut pas avoir
comment veux-tu te contrôler si tu as
l'impression que les mec il va faire du
mal à ta famille je comprends la colère
et la peur c'est dans ces cas-là
tu tires mais ça n'est pas de la colère
si on n'est pas capable de se contrôler
il commence à tu te contrôler tu es dans
l'urgence dans la peur on a peur que
vous pas déconner tu es dans le noir
ça s'appelle de la défense en faisant
des exercices de tir tu as un chef
contrôle
non
de devenir un bon tirage
ah j'espère rater donc Daniel Daniel
juste qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui te
dérange dans notre époque en général
pour dire voilà qu'aujourd'hui c'est
parce que c'est un truc que tu disais
pas avant ça non pas du tout parce que
il y a un tel sentiment d'impuissance
par rapport à des situations quand je
dis l'impuissance c'est de se dire mais
c'est pas juste c'est pas normal on
devrait pas vivre comme ça on devrait
pas avoir ses angoisses là on devrait
tous ce qui a été cité tout à l'heure
que ce soit de la petite Lola ou le père
qui a récupéré le type qui montait pour
aller revoir sa fille d'une manière
honteuse il y a un moment est-ce que
c'est un monde normal il y a toujours eu
des tortues il y a toujours eu des
criminels mais c'était pas aussi
banalisé que maintenant c'est effrayant
c'est ça tu trouves qu'aujourd'hui c'est
tentant des trucs que tu entends pas
avant
non il y en avait sûrement mais
aujourd'hui c'est plus que banaliser
c'est vraiment effrayant dans la mesure
où il y a un sentiment d'impuissance
complète ce sentiment d'impuissance on
fait quoi on peut pas dire c'est la
justice parce qu'elle peut la police a
fait ce qu'elle peut et les gens les uns
par rapport aux autres pour s'entraider
parce que heureusement que les gens
s'entraident dans la mesure du possible
bon mais c'est un peu effrayant c'est
tout
oui vous êtes pour la création de milice
ah non pas du tout non parce que ça ça
dégénère très vite je suis je suis pour
essayer de prendre les situations telles
qu'elles sont de demander aux hommes
politiques d'arrêter de nous raconter
des bobards on va embaucher les 10000
150 000 de plus on les voit jamais
arriver ah non non les milices faut
faire gaffe ça c'est un piège donc c'est
des forces individuelles et moi j'ai une
question c'est être prudent anticipé
peut-être que ça n'arrive jamais c'est
ce qu'on souhaite mais moi vous m'avez
posé une question je vous en pose une
vous avez une arme quelqu'un entre chez
vous vous pensez légitimement qu'il doit
faire du mal à votre famille non il faut
qu'il le fasse si vous avez un flingue
face à c'est un cambrioleur qui veut
vous cambrioler vous tirez
bah si c'est un cambrioleur il a pas
l'intention de prendre une balle
peut-être qu'il va s'arrêter
la loi sur quelqu'un qui pénètre chez
toi la nuit je crois que ça soit quand
même
il faut que ça soit proportionnelle
c'est-à-dire un voleur c'est pas
quelqu'un qui va venir me tuer il est
venu il vient pour prendre mais s'il a
l'intention et qu'il a une qui vient
notamment depuis lui piquer la sienne
que c'est tout
simple
c'est sympa alors la loi la loi la loi
elle dit ça la loi n'est pas pénalement
responsable la personne qui devant une
atteinte injustifiée envers elle-même ou
autrui accomplie dans le même temps un
acte commandé par la nécessité de la
légitime défense d'elle-même ou d'autrui
il y a cependant je vous le dis beaucoup
de conditions précises pour que le terme
de légitime défense soit validé
l'agression doit être je cite injuste
réel et actuel et la riposte simultanée
nécessaire volontaire et proportionnel
c'est ça qui est c'est le proportionnel
qui est voilà
non mais vous avez les papiers du tu
vois non mais c'est ça c'est c'est la
proportionnalité qui pose problème et
c'est ça qui a posé problème dans
différents cas à chaque fois bien sûr
quel degré de menace est-ce que je
pouvais tirer un voleur qui vient voler
et qui a pas l'intention de faire mal ou
tuer qui a surtout l'intention de se
tirer comment tu fais dans la même
situation que quelqu'un qui a comment
vous allez le savoir qui n'avait que
cette attention
on va pas on va pas faire un jeu de rôle
pour savoir est-ce que là il est très
méchant ou pas c'est au moment où les
choses se passent qu'on est capable ou
pas j'en sais rien je vous dis
franchement j'en sais rien mais si
j'étais dans une situation où
franchement la vie de mes proches et en
danger mais véritablement je pense que
ma réaction elle serait désespérée et
tant pis pour l'autre c'est pas plus
simple de tirer avant de se poser les
vraies questions après dans ces cas-là
on va faire un grand cinéma mais on
rentrera dans la proportionnalité et on
y sera pas ton adresse pardon ton
adresse c'est une vraie je te donnerai
l'adresse tu t'entraîneras sauter le mur
je suis pas d'accord du tout avec Daniel
mais je reconnais que c'est une vraie
tendance hein Cyril le disait
c'est une façon de penser que j'avais
pas il y a quelques années
nouvelles qui est Daniel pour la je suis
inquiète pas obligatoirement pour moi
parce que je suis inquiet de ce que
disait Gilles juste titre par rapport au
potentialité de milice c'est aussi par
rapport à la peur qui commence à être
partout et les accidents arriveront ils
arriveront pas avec des armes
obligatoires avec des couteaux de
cuisine avec des choses insensées parce
que il y a un moment où là l'erreur dont
tu parlais tout à l'heure va peut-être
arriver quelqu'un qui venait juste pour
piquer des trucs bah peut-être se faire
flinguer et ou tuer bon mais c'est dans
ces cas-là en général
pardon flinguer ou tuer c'est pareil
ça dépend du type que tu utilises